[Music]
right off the top of your head what is
one thing that you know for a fact
someone under the age of 15 will not
know anything about hair loss grew up
with the age of 15 yeah like they were
just like what is that oh they never
knew the struggles of how to find porn
oh yeah oh dude when your Nintendo was
[ __ ] up and then how to blow on the
cartridge
they never know that or what property
taxes for well don't find out I don't
know - but then shifted I see floppy
disks yeah like things like that yeah
like payphones like there's a lot of
kids under the age of 59 you don't know
what a payphone even a home telephone 11
don't know what they look like a rotary
phone or beating each other up like only
bullying the people that you liked how
about not knowing where in the [ __ ] you
are and you're driving
no you're like and then you don't you
can't know where you are in the entire
world by zooming out of your map on
accident sure you have to talk to human
being yeah being a Thomas guide or I get
mad quest but then I bring it yeah you
have to print it out beforehand I hate
that cousin you bleep you if you mess up
on any of the directions you can't
actually find your way back
[ __ ] man I printed directions I need
directions to get back me to the
original direction dude I could have
never worked at a gas station back then
because I never know where the [ __ ] and
I'd be somebody's lifeline
I'm so bad person this cutter we had to
do come in and I'm like hey man all I
know how to do is sell the soda I just
know how to get from my house to here
that's it yeah you go to the 76 man go
to the 76 station remember phone numbers
yeah or writing them down and like
penny I was tending paper cuz um I have
this list here of 28 things people under
your 15 won't believe Millennials have
to suffer through so number one is
tapping like 17 numbers just to text
hello through t9o to be like 4 4 3 3 9 9
9 and that that that is the hey like to
write hey I remember and this is so bad
but this is before was illegal but I
remember driving and like not looking at
my phone at all and I could just be
texting g9g9 - yeah I remember that's
the one thing I do remember I do kind of
miss it's just like not needing to look
but I just already knew like memorized
yeah I watched that one scene from
Departed where leo is like like
undercover and he's trying to text some
[ __ ] to his boss and he's doing it
through his pocket when it's on his
phone and yeah like they couldn't make
that movie now yeah like it's just
obsolete that technology yeah it is I
missed that okay another one is going to
a designated room to use the computer so
I just went to the computer room I hate
to use a computer yeah I used to work at
an internet cafe when I was 15 my
friend's parents said that he was
jacking off too much so they made him
put the computer in the living room
living room thank you yeah when they
were gone we just started beating off in
the liver yeah that's amazing
the couch is gone crusty about four
years ago and this is this isn't even
that long ago Nicky was I had to drive
Nicky to go get her car whatever the
[ __ ] she does this thing that a lot of
people do where they go get their car
diagnostic didn't go get it all taken
care of
I don't do it until something's falling
off yes there we go it's all about the
preventive care though
yeah yeah exactly right fall for any
action okay no so I was driving behind
Nicky so that I could I could pick her
up and when her car's getting serviced
she I didn't bring my cell phone with me
because I thought well I'm with her the
whole time so she's a [ __ ] speed
demon Susan we're out of there she's
[ __ ] gone down the street blowing
like
in lights and [ __ ] just she's not room
he turns on Eminem and just [ __ ]
start I know she is do I know she is
Bernard okay I'm behind her [ __ ] I'm
like where the [ __ ] am I am I going I
know I know what kind of car she has
it's uh it would be a Honda dealership I
don't know where the [ __ ] to go because
I'm supposed to follow her the whole
time
she left me smoking me all the way on
the dust Wow so then I don't have my
phone with me and then not kidding my
tire blows oh I was like [ __ ]
I couldn't even like I was like it was
that it was the kind of blown out words
like yeah so I was like [ __ ] I can't
even do the preventative measure to know
I maybe should have yeah I should think
they have you checked the tread you
would have known it when that pops oh
he's not - that's so true because back
in a day without phones or anything and
that just happened you just had to wait
so I was [ __ ] I couldn't tell Nikki
she would be dropping this [ __ ] off of
it where the [ __ ] did he go and then I
had to go to I had to walk to a subway
and ask to use their internet and the
guy was super nice he's like sure I got
like a little little Chromebook that I
use for the books or whatever so he let
me log on there
cuz I don't know Nikki's phone number oh
I was like what the [ __ ] is her phone
number like all I do is I hide text it
was like he's the only no phone number
that I know that other than my own do
you still know your I don't were phone
number now after that [ __ ] I [ __ ]
memorized it but I but dude I had to I
had to Facebook her dad and private
message him because I know that he's at
work hey all right
emailed him I was like cuz I know is her
dad's email cuz it's very boring email
you don't know her email I know her name
but I know she's not gonna be checking
for ARIMA I emailed her - okay so I had
to I had to email her dad and then be
like yo can you call Nikki and tell her
that I she smoked my ass and that I have
exact Lauren yeah yeah basically that I
had I'm stranded - I loved to have seen
Nikki's dad's reaction you [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah
like you can drive over 35 at a 55
[ __ ] damn so how'd you like and
finally what happened well he reached
out to diggie and then she was able to
pick me up she's like what I what
Starbuck I mean subway you had to figure
that out yeah it's pretty compelling in
Subway's but that made me remember the
tech this kind of [ __ ] I'm like man back
in the day you couldn't do any of this
[ __ ] yeah if your car just [ __ ] up
you just gotta wait for a friendly man
to help you out you're just I'm by the
side of the street and like this yep
you could do that if I do that people
ain't pulling over some white guy kind
of flash me it's cuz of flash or history
look flashes are always white guns
that's why you can't wear a trench coat
okay moving on on this list there's this
thing dildos
RCA if you remember using these other
kids that sometimes RCA cables RCA
cables but you don't use HDMI cables
sometimes I that's all I got well that's
more like VHS or like games and [ __ ]
right DVD player that's old because
nowadays everything is HD because if
that's RCA you're not getting an HD
picture at all in the audio so yeah
everything so isn't it called an RGB
cable [ __ ] it no no okay well wasn't RGB
you just Oscar us I tried to but I feel
ok here's another one
kids today will never know what it was
like to take a ton of pictures of these
have to wait a week to find out that
they were used I still kind of use those
you know I was I liked the permanence of
it you got one chance I have this shoe
box full of I have a shoe box full of
old memories and I have one undeveloped
disposable camera still but I can't
remember which era
I took why don't you just take it what
kind of evidence is on mass I don't know
if it's high school or early college or
less what could it possibly be like the
worst of all worse but like you can't
breathe pictures oh my god
I guess I can but I think this guy's
like
have brought that oh [ __ ] I was so cold
my god I was so [ __ ] stupid
I remember my sister bought save up
money and bought like a like one of
those nice little canvas and I was like
you're so [ __ ] stupid
I literally just bought a camera for $10
and then I just took the stupid
cardboard thing off of it and it's the
same [ __ ] I thought I thought it looks
the same looks like an expensive camera
and it does the same [ __ ] like you're
literally dumber than [ __ ] remember you
have to load it up for the for the flash
anyway and then you could click it yeah
I liked to just hold it and then make it
go I'm [ __ ] flash it in my friends
eyes I missed that noise
I remember thinking when I was a kid
that actually like when digital cameras
like brand new I remember thinking I had
a digital camera because it was it was
like metallic like exterior and it did
have like a flash on it and stuff but I
still had to use film but because of the
fact that it was all metallic looking
I'm like yeah I have a digital camera
it's in the future guys so I bought a
bunch of those for my first date with my
girlfriend to be like super cute oh then
we have a bunch of pictures from my
first date now I stole a cousin like
shortly before I asked her how she was
telling me about how her hard drive like
broke and she lost a bunch of pictures
you know so I want to be like super
Mounties we will never lose yeah that
would be super cute and then so then
when I asked her out on our date I
brought a bunch of a bunch of these
disposable cameras I'm like hey now you
can't you know lose any pictures of us
oh my god that's [ __ ] preventive care
another one says I feel sorry for
Netflix era kids they will never know
the high stakes adrenaline of running to
the bathroom slash fridge slash bedroom
in a single ad break with a beckoning
call of a sibling screaming its due
hurtling over furniture to get back in
time that's so true I remember I would
try to squeeze in pee breaks yeah like
in like with the ad breaks is I'm like
oh my god
I gotta be so bad but I can't miss his
show he had a poop we were screwed we
all had the same childhood except part
was locked in the closet
TV taped up watch TV once my mom came
home for like thirty minutes to an hour
and I remember I would have to split up
my shower did you shower yet so I'll be
watching like like Wayans brothers or
something that's like run into the
shower and I just turn on the water and
then I'm putting like shampoo in my hair
and I come back out so I'm sitting
watching TV three or four times
no no but I'd break it I break it up
just like a watch it Wow what were you
watching
I don't know some stupid show Family
Matters Yeah right it was always the
stupidest [ __ ] like that but you had to
see what was gonna happen yeah
especially before commercial they always
did that [ __ ] to you where it's like
it's like uncle walks in the fingers
yeah cliffhanger like he's turns into
Stefan he's like hey girl Dannan and or
the fact that back in the day we had to
if we wanted to listen to music if we
wanted to have a cell phone if we wanted
to take pictures we all we had to carry
all these different items yeah in our
pot make your iPod your phone exactly
got your camera the guy you're not the
heaviest pockets ever dad but we really
needed purses back in the days I
remember having a Walkman and a [ __ ]
speak like like your radio right when
your favorite song comes on you just
have you just hit the record button so
right so you get like a part of you play
it back later right yeah but it's like
distorted cuz you just push it on to
this [ __ ] speaker or in the 90s and
80s you know like that you got the guy
that's walking down the street with like
a yeah box there's none of that now yeah
well no it's like a small version of it
they're still annoying as people walking
down the street with their music lesson
but you can talk like this like a cool
guy yeah you can't Flexer your guns all
doing it out of ice I know you have a
big with with a tape that has two songs
that you have to keep flipping back and
forth and it's the same [ __ ] song
over and over I thought these guys are
just giving themselves tinnitus too
while we give them salsa hands it was
cool Steve just like how it was cool for
us when we were going to school to just
like have one strap on your backpack and
you get scoliosis you also never know
the feeling of watching Saved by the
Bell
when it was like on live I'm thinking
this shows really cool
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]